ومن الخرطوم سالنا الناس وسالنا
السودانيين على تعليقهم على الدراسه
القائله بان اسلاف البشر من السودان نتابع
ردود الافعال
السودان بؤره العالم واقع في منتصف العالم
ماشي ساهل دليل انه يكون
الانسانيه او البشريه ابتدات منه
الاكثر حاجه
من السودان الدراسه دي انا بالنسبه لي
يعني ايمان شديد لانه يشيل
التاريخ القديم همم او السودان من الدول
الفيه التاريخ القديم يعني مثلا الاهرامات
في السودان في نهر النيل في الفجراوي اذا
هو فعليا في اتجاه الدراسه من الافضل انه
الناس تواصل في الدراسه لانه فعليا
السودانيين دفع زي دي لانه احنا يعني طوال
تاريخنا الفائده من المشاكل الاساسيه اللي
قاعده تواجهن انه احنا ما عندنا سرديه
تاريخيه نبني علما انه بحث
جوجل انه السودان اصلا مشاريع الناس يا
غالي علي ودي الرؤسسات جامعه اكسفورد برده
عامله عليه دراسات همم يعني الحقيقه دي لو
طلعت حقيقيه بس السودان هيبقى يعني هيكون
عليه يعني هنرتفع يعني